en fait un châssis
cash
le baiser dans le boîtier et si on prend
le pc en lui-même voyez que l'unité de
fonctionnement ça n'excuse ça
[Musique]
aujourd'hui je vous parlais ordinateurs
du futur mais justement je vous parlais
aussi jeux vidéo parce que les jeux
vidéo c'est vachement cool justement jeu
intéressant oui là c'est une vidéo qui
réalise un partenariat avec période pour
vous parler d'un jeu qui s'appelle
founding donne at war je sais pas si
vous jouiez quand vous étiez plus jeune
moi c'est un truc en tout cas quand je
jouais détrône kingdom un athois me
rappelle les jeux auxquels je jouais
quand j'étais plus jeune les gens que
j'aimais bien les jeunes dont l'enfant
donc ça c'est cool c'est un jeu qui se
fait directement sur le navigateur de
votre pc pc ou mac du coup pas de
problème d'heure vous avez envie ça
marche
vous le prenez vous ouvrez vous jouez
extrêmement facile d'aller en fait il
n'ya pas d'applications à télécharger
c'est extrêmement simple vous ouvrez
vous loguez vous jouez directement pour
fermer ou vous soyez vous avez encore
d'union bureau quel que soit votre
navigateur vous pouvez changer d'ordi
sans aucun problème et vous avez
toujours votre jeu qui est là qui est
dispo pas comme vous rentre à la maison
vous jouez vous allez au devant une
petite pause vous allez jouer ça c'est
vraiment très pratique
l'inscription est hyper rapide et
graphistes sont cools moderne est sympa
c'est chouette cède aux pointes à 100
vous avez une grosse communauté derrière
vous pouvez vous unir dans des clans
pour jouer avec d'autres joueurs pour
les collaborer pour vendre des ennemis
vous partagez vos ressources pouvait
discuter dans d'être chaque nouveau si
joindre un désordre officiel vous
entoure et d'alliés fiable pouvez même
vous créez votre propre ordre vous
pouvez conquérir le progrès mais sur
l'entière contrôler des nombrils des
armes et tutti quanti pouvez échanger de
ressources agro petits camarades
conquérir la forteresse droit vous mener
des recherches vous entraîner une armée
vous armer votre héros et vous le
préparez pour les batailles goethe est
absolument gratuit rejoigne son kingdom
à touarga les liens que vous aimez en
bas dans la description et recevait un
super bonus de 200 pièces d'or pour bien
commencer croyez moi le jeu est cool je
ne peux que vous recommander
on est aujourd'hui au louvre pourtant
les daims et wendel qui s'appelle will
transformation j'ai été voir je vous en
parle en quelques instants le taux qu'en
fait c'est le renouveau de ce qu'on
pourra payer ordinateur alors là on est
sûr de la cible professionnelle
ça pourrait arriver peut-être sur de la
sinne particulier tout ça hyper
intéressant parce que ça permet de voir
c'est l'avenir du pc familial pas du pc
portable et du pc de bureau
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
aujourd'hui je vous parlais un truc que
je trouve plutôt cool c'est un truc que
j'ai vu l'autre jour où nous re parler
bien évidemment je pense que vous
enregistrer en fait tout au début quand
j'étais invité c'était sur un événement
d'elle je savais pas de quelle manière
je vais pas vous en parler ou jamais
parce y avait des choses à vous dire je
suis bien trop curieux et en fait ça a
vraiment piqué ma curiosité parce que
l'idée c'est un peu le renouveau de
l'ordinateur de bureau standard à
l'ordinateur ont connaissance avec la
grande tour plutôt moche qui prenait de
la place vous avez votre moniteur et
tout ça vous le branchez ensemble
clavier souris c'est un pull la config
de base
ça s'est un peu old school c'est un peu
passé et justement il y à une solution
qui a révélé quelques années ce qu'on
appelle le all in one c'est dire que
vous avez un moniteur et dans ce
moniteur vous avez votre ordinateur
c'est une solution qui est plus joli
mais qui aussi quelques problèmes par
exemple si votre moniteur lâche c'est à
dire vous devez envoyer tout paraît
savez l'ordinateur y compris et c'est un
peu plus 10 à l'air si l'ordinateur un
problème voulu tout envoyer et le
moniteur également donc vous devez tout
changer tout dieu savoir-faire montré un
sein c'est un peu compliqué et justement
il ya une idée qui a émergé dans la tête
de dell que je trouve plutôt
intéressante c'est de se dire eh bien on
veut utiliser ce système de all in one
un peu jolie esthétique mais par contre
quand même réussir à séparer le moniteur
est l'une des centrales
et c'est justement ce qu'ils ont réussi
à faire c'est à dire une espèce d'unité
centrale qui est tout miniature petit
pas pour qu'aux grandes tours qu'on
avait avant loyers au niveau encadrement
c'est vraiment tout petit et que vous
intégré directement dans le pied dans le
support en fait donc le truc vachement
intéressant parce que vous gardez le
design et l'esprit du all in one mais
par contre vous avez pas une tour mais
allez l'idée de la tour qui est inclus
et ça c'est vachement bien
alors aujourd'hui c'est une solution qui
est pour le professionnel dès que
j'imagine dans quelques années pourquoi
pas se dupliquer par le particulier même
si aujourd'hui le marché de l'ordinateur
portable du pc portable a tellement
évolué que je sais pas quelle place
s'ils restent sur le marché pour les
ordinateurs de blueant peut plus
classique mais je représente 8 continue
à exister équipe est une vraie belle
solution notamment pour ceux qui veulent
des grands moniteurs et qui veulent pas
s'embêter avec une tour à côté
[Musique]
c'est donc une solution qui est flexible
invisible innovantes et évolutif l'usagé
en voit très clairement ses ordinateurs
de bureau du grand moniteur avec
suffisamment puissance alors par contre
le point un peu négatif et tout ce
qu'elle est bien je sais pas forcément
fait pour tout le monde c'est à dire que
vous n'allez pas voir une carte
graphique hyper performantes
hyperpuissante notamment si vous allez
faire du gaming
de la même manière que ceux qui ont
besoin beaucoup de performances je pense
aux graphistes qui ont beaucoup de calme
qui ont à voir des projets un peu lourd
je pense aux vidéastes c'est pas
forcément fait pour vous parce que vous
allez pouvoir aller jusqu'au maximum je
croise anitele core i7 64 giga de ram 1
tera de stockage ssd et 2 tera hdd donc
droit c'est plutôt pas mal a priori
avait pas d' intel core i9 à voir
comment les choses évoluent parce que je
me projette un peu c'est plus cela delà
de la prospective aujourd'hui on s'est
d'abord un peu plus loin dans le futur
comment pour être l'ordinateur personnel
de demain à l'intérieur de la maison
ça existe aujourd'hui en tout cas ça
arrive le 23 septembre pour le
professionnel pour le particulier
peut-être dans les années à venir en
fonction des usages à voir si les
retailers isbergues ça peut être
intéressant je pense qu'il ya marché ça
pourrait arriver mais pour l'instant ce
n'est pas le cas au niveau de l'écran
c'est aussi intéressant ce que vous avez
deux types de pied il ya un pied qui
fixe la vous pourrez prendre un moniteur
de 19 pouces à 24 pouces de n'importe
quelle marque donc c'est ça qui est
assez cool en fait c'est que c'est très
ouvert et par contre si vous voulez
aller jusqu'au 27 pouces et bien vous
avez le pied amovible qui vous le permet
et je vous dis une fois de plus l'idée
c'est que c'est un système qui est pas
fermée qui a assez ouvert donc si vous
avez un moniteur de je sais pas quelle
marque moi ça me saoule compagnie
consorts ou autre vous pouvez
complètement le maître l'adapter ça
c'est bien on a une particularité chez
elle voyez ça c'est les quatre bébés
on va d avoir illégalement ici les vraie
vie ce visa est simple soit je vais
mettre un écran que je trouve encore
soit je suis dit j'ai un client dell où
je suis intéressé par le principe
attachera pitel et c'est vraiment
beaucoup plus rapide parce que là il
faut visser les capistes ici en fait
l'écran il arrive que la claque est on
est on est on est branché c'est vraiment
d'une simplicité entre acheteurs et en
plus le truc qui est intéressant c'est
qu'au niveau de la connectique c'est
quand même une unité qui va avoir en
fait une connectique assez riche plus
qu'à la du réseau filaire on a de l'usb
ici suffisamment pour servir en fait
tous les périphériques classiques comme
les souris clavier traditionnel que vous
avez 100 bureaux et surtout vous avez de
type c'est le type c aujourd'hui c'est
c'est la connectique clé de ce module
vous à les brancher votre unité centrale
bien évidemment sur secteur et ensuite
vous débranchez votre moniteur en usb
type c'est donc celle usb type c'est
qu'il a récupéré le signal vidéo dans un
sens et dans l'autre et qui vend plus à
l'alimenter ça c'est bien leur après par
contre si vous avez un vieux moniteur
peut toujours utiliser son à lima par le
brancher autrement et le brochet de
l'autre côté ça marche aussi
et quand on veut monter le l'ensemble
on va vie à brancher les câbles qui nous
intéresse on les passe comme ça dans les
différents ports et après on vient
positionner le
le châssis
et une encoche leïla est en place et en
fait le goûter au démarrage il est sur
le dessus
les biens cachés voilà moi je trouve ça
intéressant je sais pas vous ce que vous
en pensez l'idée s'est un peu fait qui
montre bien la voilà voilà à quoi
pourrait ressembler l'ordinateur du
futur dans quelques années voilà un peu
comment peut se dessiner l'avenir
l'ordinateur personnel parce que bon je
vous dis une fois de plus l'idée d'avoir
un espèce de tour qu'on m'a posée à côté
alors ça sent exalté de beaucoup de
performances et des besoins un peu
particulier mais l'idée d'avoir de la
flexibilité comme ça moi je trouve que
c'est génial ça vaut vraiment de l'or je
sais pas ce que vous en pensez
est ce que vous trouvez que c'est une
bonne idée est ce que vous trouvez ça
intéressant le fait d'abord
effectivement et bien un ordinateur qui
est tout inclus l'idée du all in one
mais avec cette flexibilité derrière en
plus de ça vous pouvez modifier la ram
vous pouvez modifier votre vers 16h20
paris en tout cas plutôt plutôt
intéressant a vous de me dire ce que
vous en pensez en bas en commentaire
comment est-ce que vous verriez vous vos
côtés le pc du futur est ce que le ps
fera pas du pc portable je pas vraiment
du pc à la maison
est ce que cette idée de all in one vous
séduit est ce que vous craignez un petit
peu justement le système de panne et est
ce que cette idée justement parce que je
vous présente aujourd'hui en cette
solution de bell qui s'appelle optiplex
assez le 7070 ultra comment vous trouvez
ce système là l'idée d'avoir tout comme
un espèce de all in one mais
complètement modulable est ce que vous
trouvez ça bien pas bien intéressant pas
intéressant marque et matous sarments
commentaires et est ce que ça vous de
vote que je vous parle un peu de techno
qui pourrait potentiellement arriver à
l'avenir
et s'il se projetait un peu dans le
futur dites moi si ça vous plaît oui non
quoi comment parce que ça que je peux
quand même pas mal de salon pouvoir
bouger notamment le cs
en janvier on va beaucoup de projets un
peu potentiellement qui pourrait arriver
plus tard chez nous peut-être ou
peut-être pas c'est pas un peu de voir
un peu sentir un peu les tendances de
sentir le marché
moi si vous voulez plus de contenu comme
ça ça vous intéresse et puis d'ici là je
vous embrasse un feu de gros bec comme
d'hab partie vous bien à deux matchs à
eau